well you'd think that violence physical
attacks and threats in our political
system would shock all of us but at this
point unfortunately nobody is really
surprised it almost seems normal
it was just last year that a progressive
activist tried to murder an entire field
of Republican lawmakers practicing
baseball he gravely wounded one of them
strangely you didn't hear calls for gun
control in the days after that happened
and at this point we've practically
forgotten it ever happened at all and so
the cycle has accelerated using force
against Republican officeholders and
conservatives now seems like a feature
of our political landscape so what is
this really about suddenly this kind of
rage is everywhere you've seen tape like
that for the past several months but who
exactly is it aimed at what is the point
well Republicans obviously are the focus
of most of it conservatives more
generally anyone else who descents from
the one true faith of cultural leftism
but really the target is the country
itself the left is angry at America they
say so all the time this is not the
Democratic Party you grew up in or that
you remember if you're over 30 that
party may have stood for some bad ideas
and it did but there was never really a
question about its fundamental loyalty
to America or the people who live here
the party of FDR and LBJ even if Bill
Clinton was basically a patriotic party
was an American party not anymore in
2018 anyone who considers America a
distinct physical place with meaningful
borders in its own history and
traditions and language and culture and
values won't feel comfortable in the
democratic party indeed may not even be
allowed in that party to modern
Democrats the leaders of the party
America is an economy with land attached
it's a massive private equity scheme
from which they are benefiting it's
people are interchangeable human widgets
to be discarded and replaced when
usefulness expires was it always this
way was this always what America was
like you might ask
shut up they'll explain before Obama got
elected America was truly a horrible
place a nightmare
watch New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
explained we're not gonna make America
great again it was never that great it
was never that great so the guy who
inherited his job from his dad Cuomo's
remarks got some coverage on this
channel but they were hardly unusual for
Como's party before she found the
hashtag me soon movement senator
Elizabeth Warren spent a lot of time
telling audiences what an awful country
this is here's one example the hard
truth
[Applause]
I mean I mean front a bit racist
front to back in other words our laws
and our police are illegitimate and
they're immoral don't worry about
violating or ignoring them Texas Senate
candidate Robert baito O'Rourke agrees
with this he recently told the crowd
that police in America murder and
imprisoned people solely because of
their skin color
now that's factually untrue it's
ridiculous and of course he didn't even
try to prove it was true but it's also a
slur on decent people of all colors who
were trying their best to serve this
country in law enforcement O'Rourke's
fellow Democrats could have said
something about this but they didn't
they're not allowed to
nobody is defend America and you will be
punished former Congresswoman Mary bono
lost her job just this week as president
of USA Gymnastics what did she do wrong
well she leveled a veiled criticism at
Colin Kaepernick that's unacceptable now
Kaepernick makes millions denigrating
our national symbols he's a hero
Nike hired him if you complain about
that though you're the villain and
you're out defending America is suddenly
a firing offense on the left